hi uh thanks for joining me today
i'm steve williams and i lead the
capillary electrophoresis r d
group within the genetic sciences
division um at thermo fissure scientific
and today i'd like to highlight the role
of sanger sequencing and fragment
analysis in the study
of sar cov2
so by a way of introduction and reminder
there are two different genetic analysis
applications that run on the family of
applied biosystems
and capillary electrophoresis systems
the first is
sanger sequencing uh using big dyke
terminated chemistry
which is used to carry out standard dna
sequencing
such as lenovo sequencing targeted
re-sequencing
variant detection and plasmid sequencing
and the second is
fragment analysis which uses
fluorescently labeled primers
to amplify specific regions of a target
dna
to produce fragments of specific size
and this has a wide range of application
including
quantitative fluorescence pcr
microsatellite analysis
sdr analysis for human identification
forensic applications and
snip genotyping thermofisher has a
suite of ce genetic analyzers that are
designed to meet the throughput needs of
users
so we have a high throughput system the
3730 which has 96 capillaries
and integrated plate loader we have a
medium throughput system
the 3500 xl
which is either a 8 capillary system or
a 24 capillary system
and also exists as a us ibd and ceibd
approved system
and then we have the latest addition to
our
instrument portfolio which is the seek
studio
system which is a benchtop instrument
very easy to use in this for capillary
system and during today's presentation
i'll discuss how sanger sequencing and
fragment analysis in the can be used in
the study of
cov2 and i'll talk about various
published articles
as well as in-house work during the
presentation and give acknowledgement
where appropriate via citation to the
authors of those
articles
so first brief introduction to
coronaviruses and the impact that they
have had
on human health so i think as everybody
knows at this point in time
um the coronaviruses are named for the
crown-like spikes on their surface
and there are four main subgroups or
genera of coronaviruses these are alpha
beta
gamma and delta and coronaviruses
human coronaviruses were first
identified in the mid-1960s
and there are seven coronaviruses that
can infect humans
and the first four in this list the 229e
and l63 and oc43 and hku1
and these all produce fairly mild
symptoms
and symptoms of a common cold in humans
and then there are three uh more serious
um
viruses that produce much more severe
respiratory infections
and these are the middle east
respiratory syndrome or mers
and then the first version of sars um
and then the version of sars that we're
dealing with now
which is the virus that causes covid19
and these coronaviruses can affect
animals and can evolve and then infect
humans through this
zoonosis process so um
back in 2003 um sars acute respiratory
uh
syndrome sarah cov the first version of
cyrus
was identified in china in 2003
2000 2002 2003 it's killed you know
nearly 650 people
in china and hong kong and it's thought
to have been
transmitted to humans uh
via bats and then into spits and then on
into humans
and 2012 was the
normal murs this was identified in saudi
arabia in 2012
um and killed over 800 people in the
middle east
um and was uh uh transferred from
dromedary camels into humans
and now we're dealing with uh the latest
strain of uh
cyrus sarcio ii first identified at the
end of 2019
in china and wuhan china and to date
has affected approximately 30 million
people
around the world i think we just passed
the 30 million mark the other day
and we have close to 1 million deaths
globally
and virus is thought to be a market
in juan and it's not currently known
uh the um the uh animal host
for this bath but it's thought to be
bats again possibly being transferred
from bats to pangolins but that
uh remains to be determined and um the
original source of the virus
can take quite a while to determine in
the case of
the first version of sas it took i think
over a decade to verify
the transmission realm
so since the first whole genome of sara
cov2 was published back in
in mid-january scientists have sequenced
tens of thousands of virus genomes
and this information has been really
valuable for studying pathogen evolution
and an academic spread so the the next
strain database is the main global
repository for all of these sequences
and tens of thousands of sequences are
now available so
ngs has of course been the the primary
technology used for whole genome
sequencing
and there are many different uh
published protocols on different ngs
platforms that are
available including the iron seek
sauro covt research panel which provides
any of the viral genome
and when it runs on the genexis
integrated sequencer
has a turnaround time of about one day
to produce a full viral sequence
so for many of the ngs protocols sanger
sequencing
plays a role to help gap fill ngs
sequences
and to confirm identified variants in
fact some of the very
early sequencing data from groups in
china used sanghar sequencing to gap
fill the
original ngs data but in addition to
that there are two published protocols
for
complete genome sequencing of the sarco
v2 virus
one from the cdc in in the us and
another from the
cdc in china
so the first genome sanger sequencing
protocol
was published by cdc back in march
shortly after
the first sequence of the virus was
published
the workflow is shown in the top of this
slide it begins with rna extraction
and then an arc
in the case of samples that have
so typically our ct values of 27 and
above would require this second pcr step
um pcr products are purified
via an exosapi purification and then a
cycle sequencing
cycle sequence using that big day
terminator version
3.1 sequencing protocol and then
separated
on the 3730 capillary electrophoresis
instrument
and for the cdc protocol there are 38
primer pairs that are needed to span
the nearly 30 000 bases of the virus and
these are tiled across the virus as
shown in the top of the slide
and in the cases of a low viral load
where a second round nested pcr
is performed primers that sit just
inside the original primers are used
and this produces amplicons in the range
of about 320 to 1 000 base pairs
and then four individual sequencing
reactions are used to sequence both the
forward and the reverse
regions of each pcr product so a total
of 148 sequencing primers are used
and a single sample takes about 18 hours
to sequence via this approach
and as i mentioned the this this
protocol is very useful for detecting
low viral load samples so the second
published protocol
shown in the bottom of the slide is very
similar approach um it tiles
um amplicons across the genome um in
this
case also 38 prime of paris are used uh
producing amplicons in the range of 600
to 1400 base pairs in length
a difference being here is that a rapid
amplification of cd
cdna ends race approaches used to
sequence the
um the three prime and the five prime
end of the virus
um so there are a number of sangha
sequence full genomes in the
in the next strain database um
particularly from regions where access
to expensive ngs instrumentation and
expertise is limited
and also for samples that
are very low viral loads anger
sequencing is often a preferred choice
so beyond sangra beyond sequencing the
entire genome
um sanger also has a significant
role to help understand the host
response to the virus
um the life cycle of sarcob2 infection
begins
with the entry of the virus into the
cell through the h2 receptor that's
shown in the top
uh left of the slide and the sweat
region of the virus binds to ace2
through the receptor binding domain of
the virus
variation in the h2 receptor sequence
can
affect how tightly the virus binds um
it might alter a host susceptibility to
sire cov2 infection
and be responsible for person-to-person
differences that are seen in
infection so studies have shown that
there are about
120 amino acids on the outside of the
outer surface of h2
that span the interface of the receptor
binding domain of a virus
and there are two key hotspot mutations
um here
in the alpha helical bundle and these
are important for
cyrus cov2 binding and these are lysine
31 and lysine 353
and sanger sequencing can be used to
identify different variants
in this region so antibodies
from vaccination or as a result of
infection
um target the receptive binding domain
of the spike protein they neutralize the
virus
by binding in this region and block
entry to the cell
so therapeutic neutralizing antibodies
you know also target this region spiked
protein
and there's somewhere on the order of
about 20 different monoclonal antibodies
um that are that are currently in
clinical trials
um as treatment options for the
infection with coronavirus
and there are many more that are in
pre-clinical development as well
so although mutation rates of the virus
are slow
um some changes in the receptor binding
domain have been seen in some isolates
and it remains important to monitor uh
the virus for changes of sequence in the
receptor binding domain
surveillane is about 183 amino acids and
so it can easily be sequenced by sanger
sequencing
and there's no need to sequence the
entire virus for this purpose
so after the virus has entered the cell
a newly formed virus is ingested by
antigen presenting cells that's shown in
the diagram which go on
to display fragments of the virus and
can activate
t helper cells which then go on to turn
on b
cells which produce antibodies
against the virus or to activate
cytotoxic t cells which can destroy the
virus
so b cells can be isolated from patients
infected with the virus by using the
spike protein as bait
and then a technique like flow cytometry
to isolate
individual b cells and there are
well-established protocols for saying a
sequencing of heavy chain
and light chain regions of antibodies
that have been recovered from b cells
so this is really useful for identifying
type binding antibody sequences
um
finally as we begin to think ahead to
the prospect
of an effective coronavirus vaccine next
year
the question of durability of response
in an individual
is an important question and there's a
growing
body of research that links immune
response to
variations in the microbiome composition
present in our bodies so
there are many there are as many as 100
times more bacterial genes residing in
humans than
human genes and recent data indicates
that gut microbiota can modulate the
response to vaccines
and as we'll see in the next few slides
a fragment analysis bce
approach can provide a rapid
cost-effective approach to
profiling microbiota in the gut and the
airways
so a technique uh known as iso
is pro has been developed by a small
startup company in the netherlands
called in biome
um and their approach is based on the
specific amplification of interspace
regions in bacteria
to generate fluorescently labeled
fragments that can then be separated
on applied biosystems genetic analyzer
instruments so all bacteria
have at least one in the space region
and men and many bacteria have multiple
regions
and is pro relies on length and sequence
polymorphisms
um of these interspace regions to
provide
identification of the bacteria so for
example in the bottom of this slide
show a these interspace regions for
uh this particular bacterial species
enterococcus basalis
it has four different interspace regions
is one is two ice three and is four
uh when uh after amplification of is1
and is2
you get a 377 base spread
base pair fragment um and amplification
of is3 and is4 produces
275 base pair fragment and so each
bacteria has
an almost unique fingerprint when these
interspace regions
are amplified and you can also
group different phylum of bacteria
in by using different labeled
primers so uh three different colors
shown here for three different file
and some of the advantages of this
approach um
are that it's a rapid workflow you can
get
an answer within about a four to five
hour turnaround time
does not require culture of the bacteria
and it can detect unknown and unknown
species
no need to predefine the species that
you're looking for
and in addition um it
can detect bacterial bacteria that
cannot be cultivated so our colleagues
in biome have used this approach to
examine
microbiota and nasopharyngeal swabs
collected from patients the
individuals that have been infected with
osiris-cov2
and they have used this technique to
identify
specific microbiota profiles that may be
correlated to the likelihood of
infection of the virus
they examined 135 different clinical
research samples from people ranging in
age from the very young to the very
elderly in this zero to 100 age
range um and they
um use the ios pro assay to profile um
dna isolated from the nasopharyngeal
frogs
so what you can see on the slide is a
resulting claustrogram
where the pcr status of each individual
is listed either as red or green red
being positive for the virus green being
negative for the virus
and these were independently determined
by qpcr
um and then you can you can see that um
after unsupervised clustering was
performed of all of the profiles there's
a clear
profile of the 77 samples with similar
microbiota profile in the center of the
clustergram here um and
in addition well um
so this cluster of um
this central cluster showed a very
low level or or a relatively low level
of cyrus co2 positivity compared to the
cluster
that was outside of the um
of the central cluster so in the for the
cluster about 25 percent of the
people were cyrus cov2 a positive and
outside of this cluster this rose to 47
percent
and in addition um
data that's not shown in the slide
indicates that older individuals were
actually enriched for this
h signature which poses the question
whether there is an age-dependent
pharyngeal microbiota signature
that has an increased susceptibility so
further and more detailed analysis that
this dataset can be
found in this publication that's listed
on the slide
or alternatively there is a poster that
will also be presented in this
conference that
goes into more detail into the data
analysis and the conclusions
so i want to switch gears now and talk
um a little bit about the use of sanger
said zoonotic um so it's wide
recognition the united disease is the
growing threat in fact the cdc estimates
that more than
every 10 people can be spread from
animals and
in fact three out of four new or
emerging infectious diseases actually
animals into people and they can we can
pass
um either directly um from an animal
into a human for example if we discussed
um andromedas uh we're responsible
uh for directly transferring the
mers virus and of course we have a bird
flu and swine flu that can be directly
transferred into humans
or they can start from a viral source
such as the bat and pass through
another animal either a civet as in the
case of the original sars or
it's postulated that the pangolins are
the intermediary
uh hosts um for the cyclov2 virus
so there's a growing need for assays
that can detect pathogens
that can pass from humans to animals to
humans
and also to identify the natural
reservoir for a particular pathogen that
has
um the possibility of infecting human
population
so sequencing can be used to address
this
to provide information on pathogens in
animal and animal hosts that are
closely related to humanized versions
and more likely to cross the
species boundary so one
approach that has been used for this
purpose
that is has capability to
identify all currently recognized and
potentially future
emergent coronaviruses is an rt pcr
amplification based approach
followed by sequencing of a particular
region of the coronavirus this
rna-dependent
rna polymerase region of the virus in
the orth
1ab region and this approach is
described in the publication listed at
the top of the slide here in the journal
of clinical
virology but has been widely used by
others as well
the approach consists of two different
pcrs that use degenerate primers
a first pcr that produces
an ampliton about 670 bases in length
with degenerate forward and reverse
primers and then a second pcr
that is a nested approach that uh
generates a smaller fragment
again using a degenerate primer um of
about 600 base pairs and this
amplicon can then be uh sanger sequenced
and to confirm the identity so with this
approach you know there are a large
number of coronaviruses that can be
identified
um and the assay shows uh
virtually no cross-reactivity with other
common respiratory pathogens such as rsv
or flu
and it can be used to routinely screen
uh individuals um whose occupation bring
them into close contact with animals
for prolonged periods of time or it can
be used for
routine surveillance in species such as
bats
which are reservoirs for viruses with
human pathogenic potential
so finally i'd like to briefly describe
an application of ce and the study of
sara cov
to detection that is based on a fragment
analysis approach
the workflow for ce fragment analysis
detection is actually similar to qpcr
it starts with a collection of the
sample in a
via nasopharyngeal swab and then
extraction
of the rna for example using
one of the kits from thermo fissure a
magmax viral pathogen nucleic acid
isolation kit
and then after rna extraction and rt pcr
step is performed with fluorescently
labeled primers um and at the end of
this the
uh fragments fleshly labeled fragments
that
have been amplified are identified
on the ce and the size of the fragment
and the color of the fragment
encodes data about which amplicon is
being detected
and the data can be analyzed via a
software such as a
gmat thermofisher so for the assay
developed at thermofisher there were
three different regions of the virus
that were amplified
one from the off-1ab region the second
from the spike gene and the third from
the nuclear capsid gene
and this results in three different size
fragments
an n protein fragment at 396 base pairs
and off 1ab
425 and s protein at 437 base pairs
and additionally an rna positive control
is added
to the reaction and to help check for
the presence of
any pcr inhibitors that might prevent
amplification
so one added feature of this assay that
i'd like to point out
is the use of multiple fluorescently
labeled primers
this allows after amplification for the
samples to be combined to be pooled
together
such that four individual reactions can
be run
on the capillary combined and read out
and run on the ce
and the fragments are then identified
based on not only the size but also the
color so
each capillary can then produce answers
for for the application from four
individuals
and the sensitivity of this approach is
is similar to qpcr methods
and more details on the protocol
and an application note can be found on
the thermofisher website as shown on the
slide
um including the sequences of all of the
primers
that are used in the assay
so by way of summary um
what i've hopefully what i've shown you
is that sanger sequencing and fragment
analysis technologies
are widely useful in the detection and
sequencing of
cov2 sangro sequencing can be used to
support
an ngs whole genome sequencing
by gap filling and confirmation of
variants but can also be used
to generate a whole genome sequence
um by itself um targeted sequencing you
know can be used
to look at v2 host response factors such
as
a sequence of h2 receptors
which the virus binds to to gain entry
to the cell or can be used to
look at the immune response
look at the antibody sequences that are
produced from individual
b cells by sequencing of the variable
regions
um there has been an assay developed
that amplifies and sequences a highly
conserved region
um of the virus the rdpr
rprp region and this can be useful
to identify the natural reservoir of the
virus or to help track
animal coronaviruses that may jump to
species
and then finally bacterial profiling
using the is pro technology
can develop a more comprehensive
understanding of how the microbiome can
influence host response to pathogen
infection
so with that i i'll conclude my talk and
invite any questions and thank you for
your time